Speaker 1: All right.
Let's talk about this bizarre change, but
welcome change over the last month, maybe
ninety six hours in which many Republicans
and some right wing media figures have started
talking about go get vaccinated.
The vaccine is good.
The vaccine is safe.
The vaccine will keep most people alive, not
everybody.
So even though the headlines has been the
headlines have been Fox News goes, provosts,
Republicans go provosts, people like Marjorie
Taylor Green, people like Tucker Carlson,
they've continued to do the Antibalas stuff.
But there is a real question, which is why
is this all of a sudden happening?
There's a great article in The Atlantic by
David Graham called Suddenly Conservatives
Care About Vaccines.
A number of leaders on the right suddenly
urge their audiences to get vaccinated in
the past day.
Why now?
And there is there are a number of different
ideas proposed here.
And the article goes through Hannity saying
that you've got to take this seriously.
Steve Doocy saying if you have a chance, get
the shot, it will save your life.
Ben Shapiro saying, get the facts.
I did, my wife did, my parents did.
Newsmax CEO Christopher Ruddy saying Joe Biden
should be applauded for making a dent in the
covid pandemic.
House Minority Whip Steve Scalise, who has
had conspicuously declined to get a shot,
announced he finally did get vaccinated.
And there is a clear shift in tone, as David
Graham writes in the Atlantic article, but
it's not exactly clear why it's happening.
One suggestion, as reported by CNN's Cantlon
Collins, was that there have been regular
high level conversations between the White
House and Fox News regarding pandemic and
vaccine coverage.
But Fox quickly denied that report.
Another possibility is simply that the covid
surge, fueled by the Delta variant, is making
some of these Republicans realize the hospitals
are getting overloaded, we could be looking
at lockdown's being reinstated here as they
are around the world.
And all of a sudden, when the stock market
dropped precipitously on Monday, even though
it more than recovered on Tuesday and Wednesday,
Republicans all of a sudden cared.
The other real possibility is that Republicans
might be doing the math that many of you have
been doing who write to me and say, David,
if you have dramatically higher vaccination
rates among Democrats than among Republicans,
could this have an electoral impact in the
sense that Republicans are going to kill off
too many of their own voters because they
are the ones not getting vaccinated and it
will cause them to lose elections?
Like, could it be as simple as dead people
can't vote?
I don't know.
I don't know, because even with that, you
have the conspiracy of I got some emails about
this a couple of days ago, people writing
to me saying, David, you people aren't doing
a good job of lying about the vaccine.
This this is the view of a right wing conspiracy
theorist.
It's a little too suspicious that mostly unvaccinated
people are getting sick and dying.
That must be part of the conspiracy.
And it's like, no, it's that the vaccines
work really well at preventing death.
So it makes sense that it's mostly unvaccinated
people that are getting sick and dying.
A couple of instances here of such a pro vaccine,
statements from people we might not expect
it from.
And then I'm going to get to another possibility
that might explain what's going on.
Here's Florida Republican governor just making,
you know, known as covid Jesus to some people,
the guy who ignored every guideline early
on and said have full capacity boxing, wrestling,
everything in Florida.
Here he is making a lot of sense.
Speaker 2: So here's, I think, the most important
thing with the data.
Yeah.
If you are vaccinated, fully vaccinated, the
chance of you getting seriously ill or dying
from covid is effectively zero.
If you look at the people that are being admitted
to hospitals, over 95 percent of them are
either not fully vaccinated or not vaccinated
at all.
Indeed.
So these vaccines are saving lives.
They are reducing mortality.
Mortality in nursing homes since we rolled
out the vaccines in December is down over
95 percent.
So a really,
Speaker 1: really strong pro vaccine statement.
And it could be motivated, again, by the fact
that Florida has had a big upsurge and now
represents the one state of Florida is one
out of five covid cases in the entire country.
Here is Mitch McConnell pleading for the vaccine.
Speaker 4: Get vaccinated,
Speaker 2: McConnell.
On that note, the Republican governor of Utah
said this weekend that conservative talking
heads are, quote, literally killing their
supporters.
Would you speak out against people who are
actually speaking out?
Well, Nancy, I
Speaker 4: don't know how I could be any more
clear than I have been.
I've been saying the same thing about vaccinations
all along the way.
Others can say whatever they choose to say.
But this is something I think I'm a good example
of, something I know the answer to.
It is not at all clear that the way to avoid
getting back in the hospital is to get vaccinated
and want to encourage everybody to do that
and to ignore all of these other voices.
Speaker 1: So what do you think explains this?
What do you think explains the change?
You know, if it was only Fox News, even though
they've denied conversation with the White
House, has there could there have been some
promise of access?
Right.
This is how stuff works.
Listen, we will give you a Joe Biden town
hall.
If you guys really help us promote vaccines,
that would be completely plausible the way
media works.
But it's not just FOX News that's doing it.
And also, FOX has denied conversations with
the White House.
They may be lying, but let's assume they're
telling the truth.
Is it as simple as the Republicans are realizing
that it's disproportionately their voters
that are dying?
Is it simply motivated by self-preservation?
I don't know the answer, but I'm curious to
hear from you.
What do you think explains this change in
tone?
And remember, it's not a total shift.
Even during these last few days, we've still
seen the anti back stuff from some Republican
members of Congress, from some on Fox News.
So it's not a 180 degree change, but it is
definitely a change in tone.
Let me know your thoughts.
We'll have more about this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
Find me on Instagram at David Pakman as well.